hello and welcome to let's play roller
coaster in three let's play episode okay
I already [ __ ] up my intro there goes
the rest of my video down the drain in
any case it's not really going to be the
best video ever it's just a bit of you
know some of those things that you
really have to do I'm not even sure
about the end result but basically what
I was going to do in this episode was do
some part works near the entrance try to
kind of finish that area even though I'm
not even going to start working on them
the parking lot and the kind of part
that is going to be leading from the
parking lots to the entrance area I also
need to do some ticket booths and stuff
like that but basically at this point I
just felt like I wanted to make some
kind of basic entrance area with some
basic paths and stuff like that so I
would actually have some kind of an idea
what the area was going to look like
because basically in a way this was kind
of modeled after the what's that thing
called again the the hotel in Disneyland
Paris kind of thing where you kind of
have that building that huge building as
an entrance and then you have some
gardens in front of it and this kind of
has a similar idea the only problems
that I was kind of running into with
this is that I'm really not that sure
about the shapes of these paths works as
you can see it's it's just a random
little thing over here kind of reminded
me of something but I completely forgot
what that was
it's really not the most I don't know
common thing I just wanted to have
something over here which would make it
look less boring than just having
nothing but having a symmetrical shape
like this I don't even know if that's
the best thing I could do honestly over
here one other thing was I've talked
about the entrance building with Jake
yesterday and he was like dude it's come
too big it's actually just be a normal
entrance building and a train station at
the same time which is kind of a good
point because the thing that you know
the Main Street is missing at the moment
and I do kind of realize this is that
you know there's this not really a huge
building at the end of it which is kind
of what you would want to have at the
end of a Main Street Disney has that
enormous beautiful castle at the end of
the Maestri and you just look at that
you can already see it at the beginning
of the Main Street and it's just
something you want to get to and it just
looks great but that's not something I
have over here but rather the huge
castle is each building is the entrance
building and I guess this is a bit of
the problem that I was going to get
anyway when I tried to have this in the
train station and the answer is building
in one building because I also just
wanted to have this entrance building be
quite large and detailed because it you
know it looks intimidating is not really
the word but it just looks cool when you
enter the park I suppose but ya know in
a way it's not really the most fitting
thing but I think I'll just keep it up
like this and have some contest wing and
near the end of the Main Street and
maybe I'll add a castle and this is I
don't know if I've really talked about
this in the let's play yet but there are
a couple of ideas about the castle at
the end of the pike I don't really know
if any of the ideas are going to be too
great because they all do have a couple
of pros and cons to them one of the
ideas was to just build one castle kind
of like Disney does it which would be a
bit of a ripoff but then again it
wouldn't be because the idea was to get
all of the different themes at least in
some way represented in the castle so it
would be a mix of Asian and European
within one course or maybe even one side
of the course of the Asian and another
side European but really I'm not sure
about this because as cool as it sounds
as an idea it's pretty good in theory
but trying to actually build that in
rollercoaster can three I feel like I
really can't do that might spend a lot
of time trying to get that right and
honestly I'm I think I'll just
completely fail on that so I don't know
about that I know the idea was to have
two consoles one on the left side where
I have the European theme I would also
have a Romanian ish Castle and on the
right side of the park where the Asian
theme have an Asian Castle but this is
also a bit of a problem because you
would want to have some kind of symmetry
within the castles but the problem with
an Asian culture is that I would most
likely go for a Japanese kind of castle
which wouldn't really have the same kind
of shape or towers and details and
things like that like a European castle
European castles have massive loads of
details on them and towers of all kinds
of fancy decorations but Japanese
consoles don't really have that in a
large sense it's just a very standard
ish structure or build so that's also a
bit of a problem another idea was to
build a Russian kind of castle
building which is another problem
because those don't really come with any
towers or anything that you'd really
want to have in the end of a Main Street
so actually the idea that I might just
go with is to just have nothing over
there but if there's anybody who has a
different idea then it's also
appreciations always welcome and I might
just look at it in all honestly I don't
think I was even the person to come up
with the idea to have a chair swing at
the end of the Main Street and so far
that's actually been working out fine
too so it might always take on those
suggestions because honestly I it's
really not going to work without just
some good feedback sometimes in any case
I should probably just talk about these
paths I've been off topic talking like I
always do this honestly it's not really
too much going on on this thing just a
couple weird part covered things yeah I
was a bit in doubt about those those
side things because as you can see they
have different colors and at first they
were all the same colors and I've
actually had some backlash about that
where even I myself kind of figured ok
why is that really necessary
it really isn't it just looks somewhat
fancy when you're looking for a
bird's-eye view but honestly there's no
real advantage to it other than just to
keep some kind of variation in there
because it doesn't really seem like the
most realistic or good-looking thing in
any way but in the end I kind of feel
okay about them with having foliage and
different fences along the side so that
was mainly one thing to keep in mind
that there is going to be quite some
foliage on this pike even having some
trees in those middle planters so it's
all going to look very different than it
looks right now not to mention that
having paths just without any
decorations on them like benches lights
and fences they look so much different
than when they are completely finished
so it's really hard to actually judge
parts before they're finished in a way
so I usually just like to kind of finish
them and then see if there's anything in
the shapes that I can improve upon
because it's really it's just hard to
judge them before you actually do that
now here is a bit of fence work I think
I remove these fences in the end yeah I
think it's just the downside to having
fences is it really makes your parts
look a lot smaller and if you have very
narrow paths then it could work if
you're for example running some balls
underneath a coaster just a short cut
somewhere
but in an entrance area I felt like nah
man that's not going to work too well
honestly and then here's a bit of tree
work finally some foliage work some
actual foliage because that's also one
thing that you know I was kind of
missing over here I want to get to the
foliage as soon as I kind of finish the
buildings and other scenery things in a
general area because that only after you
add the foliage and it's kind of similar
to how only our tea and the details to
parts you can actually judge the way
they look very well only off to us and
the foliage through an area are you able
to actually judge how it looks and
foliage it just makes so much of a
difference there I just wanted to get
that in there see how the area looks
with those trees and then decide to
either completely redo this area or to
keep it and work on it and I was content
enough about it to just keep working on
it I'm really not so sure about these
shapes but then again on one hand I
figured will I really be able to get
much better shapes in any way and would
it also be worth it to try again and
possibly feel even worse one thing that
I am considering though is to replace
those path borders at some point in time
because I don't feel too good about
having branches bedrock borders on the
size of the paths especially if there
are so many borders with having all
these curves and sideways and stuff like
that so I might replace them sometime in
the future but we're now though going
they're going to stay and really at this
point I just kind of wanted to work on
this middle thing and you'll see me
placing some fountains and random stuff
on the and the small hill in the middle
and that's kind of because I was
planning other things than just having
some random in-game objects in the
middle I actually want to get some kind
of that like some kind of statue on
which I can put the name and/or the logo
of the park because that seems like a
cool idea so that's something to do in
the future but for now I just felt like
no I'm I don't feel like doing that I'll
just do that later on because that's how
professional I am when it comes to this
stuff none definitely okay I shouldn't
pick my nose when I'm doing this I'm
definitely not professional in a sense
that these video is going to be great
but nothing I've talked about that
before you know these town upses are
really not going to be too amazing
there's a lot of testing things and
just in general kind of you know moving
around and I do feel kind of bad about
this because even though I was testing
with certain things you can never get
things right right away and I was still
pretty happy about this time that's
because sometimes sometimes I just take
hours to get something right to be very
honest on and the last dream that I had
a couple of days ago I spent more than
an hour on one roof and this was a 2 by
2 tile roof I was going through sets and
all kinds of things and that's that's
the type of stuff that I wouldn't want
to have in time-lapses because that
would mean that an entire time lapse was
made up of just me building one roof and
that that would be honestly terrible so
I guess in that sense it's still ok but
still not really the best time up
section over here and it's I don't know
about the square either it's just
something that I wanted to get here and
honestly next time we'll move on I'm not
going to do the parking lot yet because
I mean I I don't even know I I can't
that's basically it's a high cons I am
don't have enough experience I suppose
when it comes to parking lots but also I
don't feel like doing it like what's the
point it's just one of those backstage
things that I'm not really a huge fan of
because I'm more into it for the scenery
aspect rather than the theme park aspect
as a whole even though I do want to kind
of focus on that with this park more
than I usually do it is still not
something that I really look forward to
doing too much so next thing I want to
do is just to finally branch out into
the rest of the park start building that
main square and start building some
goddamn rides because that is not even
happening yet and were like eight
episodes in yeah I think this is maybe
even the ninth episode maybe I don't
even know but in any case it is really
sometime through some rides honestly
so I'll start on that pretty soon
because I actually think that's going to
be the next episode with that with that
little chair swing thingamajig and so
that's going to be cool also I just
wanted to kinda fix a couple of things
on the main street honestly and this
Tower didn't really look too good it was
exactly the same as the Tower on the
other side so at some point in time I
removed and that little tower top on it
which I got from what's that thing
called again goes to come in my station
Jim jr. yeah but that it looks a bit
derpy so I guess the best thing to do
here was
to raise that standard type of
Mainstreet roof to tiles and then see
how that looks and I think it's pretty
ok it works pretty well and that's
pretty much it when it comes to this
part by the way this will be the end of
the main street nothing else and won't
really add anything to the other side
either at this point in time I might
just add a couple of things if I really
want to change them or if I do get some
feedback of which I think yeah ok I done
goofed over there I really need to do
something about that
then there will still be some small
changes to the Main Street but these are
really just adding the final touches to
the Main Street and leaving it like this
except at some point in time I should
really try to add a trolley to that
thing I really need to get like some
kind of CT using which I can add a
trolley to that thing because it is a
Main Street after all and it is very
necessary to have its Rolly in such a
thing but yeah that's pretty much it the
next step is the next area that I want
to go into after I finish the square by
the way it's going to be the Spain /
Italy / Greece area basically the
Mediterranean European countries I think
that's pretty much it maybe a bit of
Croatia in there as well
slight touches I don't really know we'll
see at some point in time but that's
going to be that area which I'll work on
first but first I can't I still need to
finish that smait square which I think
will take about two episodes to finish
that thing because there's a lot of path
work to be worked on when it comes to
that May Square there is the chair swing
and other things but I'll talk about
that when I get to that I first want to
work on that
Italy / Greece thing and get a log flume
in there may be some other attractions
and we'll just see how it all goes I
think it should be a pretty fun it's
honestly not the first area that I
wanted to get in theme-wise but I think
it is the best area to get into just
keep a kind of good park layouts because
is the is it is going to be the main
area which is going to be to the left of
the entrance right away so I can also
kind of experiment with the backstage
areas how I'm going to do that and see
how the park layout is going to work and
the area is going to have a lot of water
maybe even a couple of fake beaches
stuff like that but I'm really way too
much ahead again I shouldn't I shouldn't
talk about that what am I
doing I am yeah this flowers this
flowers everybody knows how much I love
flowers that really even need to talk
about that I suppose that's the reason
why just wanted to add a bunch of
flowers to this main kind of area though
not too much because you know it's quick
to have a flower overkill and the best
thing when it comes to flowers it's not
mixed too many colors in one planter and
also keep them close to your pots always
keep your flowers close to your pots
unless they're flowers that don't have
to be maintained but just don't go too
overboard with the different flowers and
are thinking that respects and this
entrance area kind of works in any case
that's it for this episode I'll see you
all next episode in which I'll actually
do that square so till then